absolutely ridiculous
a month-long shortage of baby formula in
the u.s caused by a mix of supply chain
issues and a recall is putting desperate
parents on edge as they scramble to find
ways to feed their babies
for those babies who are not being
breastfed or otherwise getting human
milk formula is only the alternative and
it provides all of their nutrition
so what can parents do now and more
importantly what should they avoid
definitely do not wet it down or make
your own formula these are dangerous and
there's simply no safe way to do those
dr stephen abrams a former chair of the
committee on nutrition at the american
academy of pediatrics says that similar
to breast milk baby formula contains
protein and nutrients that are crucial
to a child's development and growth such
as calcium phosphorus iron and zinc
when you make your own you can't get the
nutrients right it's hard to do it in a
way that's sterile enough to make sure
that you're not risking infection
when you dilute the formula you're
simply giving the baby extra water that
they don't need and they're filling up
their tummies with weather and that food
it's what they need to grow
it's okay to switch baby formulas unless
your baby has special medical needs
experts say it's safe for most healthy
babies to switch to any fda approved
formula parents can find from reputable
distributors the american academy of
pediatrics warns against buying formulas
on auction sites that are not monitored
or regulated by the fda
babies have specialized problems
especially those with severe allergies
families need to talk to the
pediatrician before they switch
as major retailers like cvs walgreens
kroger and target impose purchase limits
on baby formula to avoid panic buying
and hoarding products experts recommend
checking smaller local stores and
pharmacies i've seen it for example in
stores that only sell kosher food
because they make specialized kosher
formula sometimes you'll find it in
smaller stores that you might not expect
it to find it in
at least 31 milk banks in the u.s and
canada are collecting donations from
lactating women and distributing
pasteurized milk these members of the
human milk banking association of north
america are currently helping families
facing difficulties due to the formula
shortage the problem is that most of
that milk goes for premature babies
there isn't a whole lot left for the
general use but it's as long as the milk
is pasteurized it's quite safe
although the cdc says parents who want
to give their children cow's milk should
wait until after the infant's first
birthday dr abrams says this can be a
last resort option for babies older than
six months in case of an emergency for
short periods of time a week two weeks
of time you can use whole cow milk if
your baby's not allergic
dr abrams says parents should talk to
their pediatricians about getting an
iron supplement for babies who are on
cow's milk because whole cow milk is too
low in iron for the nutritional needs
the shortage which stems from
pandemic-related supply issues worsened
after abbott laboratories a major
formula manufacturer voluntarily
recalled some products and closed a
plant
on may 16 the company announced that it
had reached a deal with the fda for the
reopening of their formula plant but a
date has not yet been confirmed
on may 18th president biden invoked the
defense production act to help
manufacturers increase production of
baby formula the administration also
launched a new program that would use
commercial aircrafts to pick up overseas
formula that meets u.s standards i'm
hopeful that the government allowing
imports and increased production will
begin to see a turnaround over the next
couple weeks but i think we're still
going to need to be very careful i don't
expect to see full resolution until
really
multiple months from now and families
need to be aware of that